[Aplausos]
[Música]
queridos amigos amigas voy a empezar
planteando un reto atentos a los datos
imaginad que tenemos un país con una
inflación por encima del 50% anual donde
casi la mitad de la población vive en la
pobreza un país con muy pocos empleos de
calidad y que tiene una escasez crónica
de divisas extranjeras y de inversión es
un país que lleva décadas experimentando
una situación de crisis económica
política y social casi constante y que
se ha quedado muy atrasado en cuanto a
tecnología productiva vamos que las
cosas no pueden seguir así os enfrentáis
a un escenario insostenible una
situación en la que sentarse y tomar
decisiones la pregunta es si vosotros
estuvierais a los mandos qué decisiones
tomar y ais
pues bien este seguro que con semejantes
problemas internos una de las soluciones
que muchos de vosotros pondréis sobre la
mesa sería este país tiene que volcarse
claramente al comercio exterior al fin y
al cabo eso le permitiría conseguir un
montón de divisas crear nuevos puestos
de trabajo atraer nuevas inversiones
hacerse con nuevas tecnologías nuevos
mercados y un largo etcétera de
beneficios al final es una fórmula que
han empleado muchísimos gobiernos a lo
largo y ancho de todo el mundo desde
españa hasta japón pasando por polonia
china o singapur sin embargo queridos
amigos amigas hay un país con muchos
muchísimos más problemas de los que
hemos descrito en este vídeo en el que
sin embargo el término comercio
internacional suena prácticamente a
herejía por supuesto se estamos
refiriendo a la argentina un país
querida comunidad que parece alérgico al
mundo exterior
ahora bien porque la argentina es tan
hostil al comercio exterior que trabas
existen como podría el país del tango y
los asados muy hechos hacer del comercio
exterior una enorme fuente de riqueza en
este vídeo vamos a responder a todas
estas preguntas pero antes antes tenemos
que ver dónde comenzó todo atentos
de la globalización al aislamiento
la argentina era un país despoblado y
pobre hasta que en el siglo 19 se
produjo un enorme cambio social y
económico el país se abrió al mundo y
comenzaron a llegar millones de
inmigrantes e inversiones que
permitieron poner a trabajar las grandes
extensiones de la pampa húmeda
a poco la argentina se convirtió en el
granero del mundo y también en uno de
los países más prósperos de toda la
tierra los carro carriles trasladaban a
los puertos de rosario y buenos aires el
producto del campo conseguido con el
arduo trabajo de los inmigrantes
europeos que habían llegado al país en
búsqueda de riqueza de esta forma las
ciudades crecían las inversiones
acumulaban y el país tenía su propia
versión del sueño americano
sin embargo todo empezó a cambiar cuando
en 1929 se desató la gran crisis una
crisis que tuvo su origen en los eeuu
pero que pronto se extendió por el resto
del mundo
[Música]
y argentina argentina no fue una
excepción a partir de ese momento fueron
muchos los que señalaron al comercio
internacional a las fronteras abiertas y
al patrón oro de ser los ingredientes
clave de la crisis algo que provocó una
enorme ola de nacionalismo
intervencionismo y proteccionismo en la
política mundial ya que amigos la
argentina fue un alumno destacado
el liberalismo económico y la economía
agroexportadora que hasta entonces
habían caracterizado al país gaucho
pasaron a ser considerados como un
modelo anticuado la opinión mayoritaria
comenzó a inclinarse porque el país se
enfocará en llevar a cabo un proceso de
industrialización interna que le
permitirá no depender de las
fluctuaciones de la economía
internacional
[Aplausos]
unas ideas que se consolidaron con el
estallido de la segunda guerra mundial y
sobre todo con la llegada al poder en
1946 de juan domingo perón
a partir de ese momento el país se iría
cerrando poco a poco a la economía
mundial siguiendo la conocida como
política de sustitución de importaciones
un tipo de política que tuvo su punto
álgido a partir de los años 70 de hecho
uno de los libros que más ha influido a
los economistas argentinos es la obra
titulada vivir con lo nuestro que a
comienzos de los 80 publicó el paul
krugman argentino aldo ferrer vivir con
lo nuestro no sé creo que no hace falta
mucha presentación el caso es que con el
breve paréntesis de la presidencia de
menem de la que por cierto ya os hemos
hablado aquí en visual político los
políticos argentinos han trabajado duro
por aislar al país del mundo bueno
excepto si hablamos de los dólares del
fondo monetario internacional- ya sabéis
que los políticos argentinos siempre
ponen primero la mano y luego cuando
toca pagar un millón de excusas
no podemos asumir ningún compromiso con
nuestra deuda
argentina amigos lejos de promover las
exportaciones ha levantado todo tipo de
barreras al comercio exterior lo que
resulta un caso completamente
paradigmático en la política
internacional y ojo porque hablamos de
una tarea que los políticos han tomado
muy pero que muy en serio incluso cuando
los resultados han sido calamitosos no
sólo no han cambiado de rumbo sino que
han pisado más el acelerador y sabéis
que eso precisamente es lo que está
haciendo el actual presidente alberto
fernández atentos
buscad el dólar
e
lo más sorprendente del caso argentino
no es que los políticos se hayan
obsesionado con poner trabas a las
importaciones con la excusa de fomentar
la industria nacional y evitar la
pérdida de divisas no es algo que han
hecho otros muchos gobiernos del mundo y
que por cierto siempre termina mal entre
otras cosas porque se perjudica la
competencia y el uso de inputs más
baratos o tecnológicamente más avanzados
al tiempo que se generan mercados
cautivos no lo más llamativo del caso
argentino es que un país que necesita
desesperadamente dólares castigue las
propias exportaciones sí sí tal cual
como lo escucháis el gobierno argentino
no para de entorpecer las operaciones
con el exterior ya sea para comprar o
para vender
da igual si eres un empresario argentino
y quieres comerciar con el extranjero en
'sospechosos ahora bien la pregunta es
cómo lo hace exactamente qué mecanismos
utiliza el gobierno argentino para
torpedear el comercio internacional pues
veréis actualmente la primera clave está
en los controles de capitales esto es en
las normas que el gobierno ha fijado
para los argentinos que quieran comprar
vender y mover dólares que como todos
sabéis es la divisa de referencia del
comercio mundial unos controles que han
provocado que en el país gaucho
encontremos dos tipos de cambio
por un lado está el tipo de cambio
oficial que en el momento de preparar
este vídeo viene a ser unos 104 pesos
por dólar y por otro lado tenemos el
tipo de cambio libre en el mercado
informal más conocido como el tipo de
cambio del dólar blue donde para que os
hagáis una idea el dólar viene a costar
el doble unos 220 pesos por cada dólar
por supuesto todas las operaciones
bancarias se realizan teniendo en cuenta
el dólar oficial que como veréis no
resulta tan sencillo de conseguir pero
empecemos os parece por ver qué ocurre
con las compras esto es con las
importaciones
[Música]
cualquier empresa grande mediana o
pequeña que necesite importar productos
del extranjero debe hacer frente a un
largo laberinto de trámites y
formularios que a la hora de la verdad
le van a hacer muy difícil conseguir las
divisas que necesitan fijados para poder
importar productos las empresas tienen
que obtener una ln a una licencia no
automática de importación licencias que
el estado argentino concede de forma
totalmente discrecional es decir que
sólo podrás hacerte con una si el
funcionario de turno considera que tu
posición de comprar el extranjero tiene
o no sentido de esta forma los
interesados están obligados a explicar
para qué y por qué quieren las divisas
pedir las con un montón de antelación y
rezar porque el funcionario encargado
del caso escuché sus plegarias y tenga
bien darle la licencia si no le da la
gana pues como se dice en españa' ajo y
agua a aguantarse y bueno pues eso
de esta forma el gobierno argentino
controla el volumen de importaciones que
entran al país y si de repente las
divisas del banco central se reduce muy
rápido pues se cierra el grifo y se
desestima muchas más licencias de lo
normal aunque eso claro está supone un
castigo muy duro para las empresas
locales que puedan enfrentarse de la
noche a la mañana a la incapacidad de
obtener materias primas o productos del
extranjero necesarios para su actividad
mala suerte esto amigos es lo que
explica que en la argentina sea habitual
que las empresas se enfrenten a una
escasez recurrente de materiales que por
ejemplo les puede impedir mejorar la
producción con reparar una máquina así
que ya lo veis el dólar oficial en
argentina es barato pero viene con
trampa eso sí un momento porque si te
llevas bien con el gobierno para ahí
puedes obtener una fuente inagotable de
riqueza porque
pues porque de facto al fijar un tipo
oficial que no tiene nada que ver con el
tipo de mercado lo que hace el gobierno
es subvencionar te las compras en el
extranjero pero insisto eso siempre y
cuando tengas su bendición si no se es
un sistema espantoso bien esto respecto
a las importaciones pero qué ocurre con
las exportaciones con las ventas al
extranjero pues amigos de entrada si
exporta es un producto y consigues
dólares el gobierno te los va a
convertir forzosamente a pesos eso sí al
tipo de cambio oficial es decir a 104
pesos por dólar y no a los 220 del
mercado real que es algo que cotiza el
dólar blue en el momento de preparar
este vídeo
[Música]
y el problema es que la economía de
argentina ante el desastre del peso está
en gran medida dolarizada de esta forma
a los costes de las empresas se
determinan en muchos casos por el tipo
de cambio del dólar blue es decir que
cuando una empresa decide exportar su
producción lo que va a recibir son pesos
a un tipo de cambio que es la mitad de
lo que valen en el mercado los dólares
que el gobierno al arrebatar
para entendernos cuando una empresa
argentina quiere importar algo se
beneficia del dólar barato el problema
es que no tiene garantizado que pueda
acceder a los dólares y cuando quiere
exportar pues termina recibiendo la
mitad de locos esto además de los
impuestos las regulaciones laborales y
bueno las trabas de todo tipo que hay en
el país es precisamente lo que explica
que a pesar de los bajos costes
salariales que hoy por hoy tiene la
argentina pues prácticamente no existan
multinacionales que quieran invertir en
el país para producir allí y luego
vender en el resto del mundo no caros
que así con este sistema se te quita las
ganas pero ojo porque aquí no termina
todo
[Música]
dado que este tipo de políticas han
destruido su sector industrial la
argentina se caracteriza sobre todo por
la exportación de productos
agroalimentarios como carne cereales o
harina productos que también consumen
los propios argentinos pues bien para
evitar que los compradores extranjeros
compitan con los consumidores locales
las empresas argentinas se enfrentan a
cuotas máximas de exportaciones es decir
que el gobierno obliga a las empresas a
vender una parte considerable de su
producción en el mercado local a precios
además fijados por el propio gobierno
todo esto puede parecer un grito muy
idílico en el problema amigos es que
reduce la entrada de divisas los
salarios y la inversión en incrementar
la capacidad productiva entonces el
resultado final es malo para todos pero
aún hay más durante los últimos 20 años
la exportación estrella de la argentina
ha sido la soja un producto que se
devora en china pero que en argentina
pues apenas se consume con lo cual aquí
la cuota de exportación pues no tiene
sentido ahora bien pensáis que esto iba
a detener a los políticos gauchos pues
si es así estáis muy pero que muy
equivocados los productores de soja
pueden exportar todas las hojas que
quieran pero a cambio de pagar un
impuesto adicional un impuesto
extraordinario
[Música]
mientras que el dólar blue que es el
dólar libre cotiza a unos 220 pesos los
exportadores de soja apenas reciben 70
pesos por cada dólar que exportan esto
es así porque el gobierno primero les
convierte en los dólares a pesos según
el tipo de cambio oficial y luego les
mete un impuesto adicional del 33% de
220 a 70 pesos por dólar exportado
pero tranquilos que aún no hemos
terminado por si todo esto fuera poco el
gobierno no para de aprobar nuevas
barreras para que vender al extranjero
sea cada vez más difícil por ejemplo los
agroexportadores deben estar inscritos
el llamado registro de operadores de la
cadena agroalimentaria algo que les
obliga a tener que hacer frente a un
montón de papeleo por ejemplo tienen que
hacer declaraciones sobre las ventas que
planean hacer el siguiente año entregar
información financiera para probar que
son solventes informar detalladamente
sobre sus empleados y los salarios que
paga verificar que las empresas con las
que actúan también cumplan con los
requisitos del gobierno argentino
etcétera etcétera resumen toda una
pesadilla
y aún hay más todavía luego una vez que
ha lidiado con el gobierno cualquier
empresa que quiera exportar tiene que
arreglarse con el control de dos
poderosos sindicatos el de los
camioneros liderados por el clan montoya
y el de los empleados del cuarto basta
deciros que la intervención de estos
sindicatos hace que el transporte en
argentina sea particularmente caro la
competencia limitada y los horarios y el
servicio un desastre y si encima no te
llevas bien con los sindicatos y no les
pagan las cuotas que exigen pues
olvídate porque seguramente te paren la
carga y no puedes hacer nada con ellos
[Música]
y estos son sólo unos pocos ejemplos de
lo que supone el día a día porque si
amigos se ha exportado en argentina es
casi una misión imposible y los datos
así lo corroboran la economía argentina
es una de las más cerradas al comercio
internacional de todo el mundo un país
que ha decidido hacer exactamente lo
contrario de lo que han hecho los países
más prósperos exactamente la receta
contraria a la que un día hizo de este
país uno de los más ricos del mundo pero
llegados hasta aquí turno para ti con
todas estas trabas te plantearías
invertir en argentina que creéis que
explica tanta obsesión contra el
comercio exterior déjanos por aquí abajo
tus comentarios y ahora si este vídeo os
ha resultado interesante no olvidéis
darle al botón de like suscribiros a
visual política un saludo y hasta la
próxima
[Música]